okay [ __ ] and we're back we're back
we're back and I think we're doing the
last mission of the dark brotherhood
[ __ ] like [ __ ] microphones better
work there we go man Lydia [ __ ] a dude
yeah may wet Oh baby I did I can't even
think of all the buzz we want to like
dick instead of my head Jesus okay so be
one loose how about you run a job for me
shut the [ __ ] up you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
Dark Brotherhood forever can't get the
[ __ ] out of here let's get the [ __ ] out
of here
what's the barrier again there we go
[ __ ] good see now never like [ __ ]
there we go and there you go my creepy
noises some of things it's creepy noises
hi Louie okay no matter where are you
[ __ ] papers no place yes I never
child as prey to their mother me with a
grief-stricken share at the wind peak is
here in da dark earth earth earth except
is gold and eliminate the dog dr. Brooks
still coming I'll tell you anything
anything just please stop sure did 5,000
grand for that torture room you better
be tortured you know I tell you some
potions inside or Shane you and out yeah
how do I got out here
grant put too much money to display down
[ __ ] lost out over here I just say
that it's like in here scar that's talk
I'll do like welding [ __ ] [ __ ] wallet
Parisa
[ __ ] [ __ ] please
where to go
horse sake ok hi miss kit what is it
away
speak with the contact
ah yes I get to go together like Jesus
is [ __ ] insane yeah [ __ ] I got it
there watch this horse all about we go
faster
[Music]
yeah what is this what the [ __ ] oh this
is the secret entrance i bought [ __ ]
giant oh [ __ ] it I gotta get out of this
town either you need to get the hold of
yourselves so you're the one from the
dark brotherhood I need you to kill the
big laborer at catalyst far and there's
the gold for the kill liars make it
painful right door it's the same dream
over and over again do you think that's
normal it's evil I tell you
great
there's this sense are you finished
aughh legging the grotesque I suppose I
should be I am one of the afflicted I'd
have been returning to high rock a
shepherd lots display that sphere Perry
expat
khalidiya [ __ ] you man
okay [ __ ] it dad get the [ __ ] out of
here
actually really just take the [ __ ]
air
thank you
hmm okay very beer to summon the dragon
bones are hundreds of you where's the
target he'll kill you too as a man go
about his business and he really nervous
we can't thank ya